love
généux
le maillon principal de
l'association je me présente je
m'appelle Jean-Luc mirlia et je suis
président d'association r association
des inclassables
réunionnés bjour
bonjour vous allez bienment on est où là
nous est chez moi c'est un peu l'annexe
aussi comme chez Isa où on traite les
dossiers administratifs on fait tout ça
déjà la récupe bah une une terrasse en
palette un fauteuil en bois récupe une
table en palette c'est parti pour de la
palette et pour de la récupe on continue
on arriv en la Réunion il y a plus de 20
ans Ben le monde associatif je
connaissais bien et donc c'est vrai que
même si j'avais des des activités
salariales il fallait quand même que je
m'occupe un petit peu d'association et
donc j'ai toujours gravité là-dedans
pourquoi parce que ça fait partie de de
moi en fait je suis fait comme ça j'aime
bah donner des coup de main j'aime
mettre des choses en place j'aime faire
partager et ben on peut pas trop changer
à ce niveau-là donc j'ai besoin de ça en
même
temps ça c'est la chaise qui avait été
faite au bazar numéro 3 qui a été faite
par deux artistes Jean-François et un
Dallon avec du bois de goyavier une
chaise de
récupération bah évidemment un t-shirt
qui a été récupéré pour faire ça et un
travail on peut regarder de précision et
cetera là je chauffe la peau quand la
peau est chauffée en fait elle est plus
dure et donc à partir de là la sonorité
est meilleure en fait sinon il fait un
peu comme une mauvaise corde quand est
pas
accordé
la musique ben permet de rencontrer
d'autres musiciens permet d'échanger moi
c'est la plus grande drogue que j'ai
trouvé sur cette planète Terre en fait
c'est ça je peux jouer pendant des
heures et des heures et des heures et
des heures et des heures des heures des
heures
alors là on est à
Saint-Paul plus particulièrement éant
Saint-Paul dans le local qui est partagé
par trois associations qui s'appelle le
Wonder building sud strockben et
l'association a dont je suis président
c'est quoi tout ça là alors là c'est
parce qu'il y a une manifestation dans
un premier temps qui a lieu dimanche qui
s'appelle le carnaval à Bouan donc qui
est géré par pôle sud et donc là il y a
pas mal de compagni qui fabriquent des
chars qui font des des choses par
rapport à çaène là c'est l'arrière scène
tout à fait c'est diffusé après le B
donc c'est pas grave on peut montrer
alors ok impeccable
superasy de cette association à la base
vu qu'elle est né il y a quand même plus
de 10 ans à la base c'était de s'occuper
des intermittents du spectacle de la
Réunion donc on s'occupait de toute la
partie je dirais comptable et l'en 2000
on a décidé de faire une orientation une
réorientation s'occuper plus de projets
associatifs et c'est là où moi j'ai pris
un peu la présidence de cette
association nous notre espace à nous
l'espace de l'association il est là-bas
en fait on a divisé le local en trois
parties donc ch chacun son son air de de
travail nous la notre elle est là-bas et
c'est plus particulièrement par rapport
à une manifestation qui s'appelle bazar
et qui a lieu en novembre mais c'est
génial ce lieu en fait ah c'est immense
c'est super c'est un cadeau de Dieu on
peut le dire on peut le
dire alors ici nous avons annelor et
nasera bonjour
nasera bonjour m actif de l'association
Isabelle Froget donc la secrétaire de
l'association d'cord aussi et puis
éedouard qui est en éedouard qui est en
pleine pratique qui qui a conçu on peut
dire aussi et participeré énormément sur
cette fabrication de chars avec naserin
aussi beaucoup passionnément il pense à
tout le monde grâce à lui
on on crée des ateliers on organise le
bazar la manifestation qui se passe en
novembre on fait le
char et voilà et d'autres choses à côté
puisque moi je fais des ateliers
marmaill je les fais aussi dans les
écoles les
garderie un petit peu une aventure dans
tout ce
bazar voilà une aventure
avec les matériaux les gens parce qu'on
fait aussi des rencontres par il y a
d'autres associations don il y a quand
même un point commun assez solidaire
dans dans dans cet endroit où on a tous
le même petit peu le même but hein de
de de récupérer les déchets de
retransformer les choses notre char nous
c'est que de la
récupération tu crois que franchement
les gens vont remarquer bah oui bah déjà
nous
hein pour nous avant tout
hein
un jour j'ai découvert le le site ce
qu'il faisait ça me plaisait beaucoup
parce que déjà chez moi je récupérais
pas mal de choses en fait je faisais
déjà pas mal de de récup de décoration
dans mon coin et en fait c'était sympa
c'était de voir qu'il y avait d'autres
gens qui le faisaient aussi donc pouvoir
partager aussi du savoirs de
connaissances d'autres techniques
excuse-moi quel heure il est 3h
Mo 3 je sais pas
Ricard deux dessinateurs hors paère là
cé c'était Hélène oui hlène qui a fait
le dessin on a le croquy là aussi les
années précédentses c'était Jeff qui a
monté son site aussi euh illustrateur
tropical aussi d'ailleurs tout le monde
est obligé d'aimer euh il ont intérêt
ouais ils ont
intérêt il y a des moments où on sent
que Ben les politiques ont besoin de
nous aussi quelque part on a aussi une
activité on montre que il y a des choses
qui peuvent se faire et au-delà de ce
qui existe déjà on peut mettre des
choses en place donc c'est pour ça que
j'aime donner mon avis et surtout dans
ce monde actuel où on est dans une
société de surconsommation quand on
parle nous du bazar et qu'on dit qu'on
fait appel à des artistes ce sont des
artistes d'abord qui ont déjà produit
donc qui ont des œuvres et là on sait
voilà quand on voit leur production on
sait que parce que il y a des gens qui
ont fait du design qui sont architectes
qui ont un œ voilà qui ont un qui son
qui sont des artistes est-ce que vous
sentez pas décalé on peut dire décalé
c'est pas le terme que j'utiliserai moi
en fait dans le sens où j'étais aussi en
Afrique j'ai de la famille en Afrique
là-bas le côte américain séduit
énormément ici à la Réunion d'autant
plus c'est vrai que le ce côté on achète
des choses on a besoin de ce matériel et
cetera tout le monde tout le monde est
pris dans cette société de consommation
elle n'a pas le regard suffisant des
fois pour prendre du recul sur ce qui se
passe maintenant j'inviterai tous les
gens à regarder des petits reportages
aussi sur Internet ou regarder des
choses qu'ils sonont il y a une petite
ampoule qui existe aux États-Unis dans
une dans un un cabinet de Pompi c'est un
petit exemple mais qui existe depuis 100
ans parce que les ampoules étit créé
pour durer à vie chose que peut-être
beaucoup beaucoup de gens ignorent c'est
des choses étaient construites pour
durer à
vie
alors ici nous sommes chez Isa donc à
camb où en fait le bureau d'association
donc on l'a remis là ça sert à quoi une
association vous pourriez faire ça entre
potes c'est un peu ça l'objectif c'est
une association de d'amis à la base et
où on essae Deah de travailler ensemble
pour monter justement les actions qui
nous tiennent à
cœur mais c'est vrai qu'à un moment je
pense se posera la question de se
professionnaliser un petit peu parce
qu'effectivement il y a il y a un moment
où le bénévolat et la bande de potes
elle atteint ses limites et où si on
veut pouvoir continuer et surtout être
crédible et faire des choses efficace à
un moment il faudra
professionnaliser un minimum cette
association
quand je parle de professionnalisation
je parle pas de profit hein mais je
parle d'avoir une structure
professionnelle qui justement puisse
porter l'association on rejoint plein de
groupements qui existent en fait en
France à la Réunion la preuve en aussi
que il y a des écoles qui ont travaillé
sur un an à Saint-Denis sur des
programmes de travailler avec des
enfants sur la rcupe il y a des
associations qui travaillent là-dessus à
la réunion des entreprises qui sont
créées pour travailler sur des palettes
il y a plein de monde qui gravite autour
de ça donc c'est quelque part on est
dans le bon dans le bon feeling je pense
qu'on est dans la bonne pensée en fait
quelque part la salle d'expo on a prévu
de la mettre juste à l'entrée à la place
du de l'endroit où on a fait un petit
espace avec des tipis là juste pour rire
par rapport au et vous allez tout
fabriquer vous-même au village westtin
en fait c'est la récupe on nous a donné
un un bingalo qui était existant c'est
une amie qui a déménager son magasin qui
a dû déménager euh donc elle nous a
donné son bagalot parce qu'elle avait
pas la place de le réinstaller donc
Édouard est allé le démonter et
maintenant on va le remonter sur le sur
le
terrain voilà deh ouais on peut dire
bravodard c'est
clair c'est énormément d'investissement
vous vivez comment vous vivez quoi vous
avez un job à côté c'est que bénévole
c'est vous le vendez non je travaille
aussi à côté c'est que la passion ça ça
c'est la passion ouais ça c'est le
weekend ou les moments où il y a pas de
travail
on veut plus cher c'est que ce projet là
c'est pour ça que je suis revenu cette
année aussi c'est qu'il puisse durer
qu'il puisse perdurer qu'il puisse créer
aussi de l'emploi qu'il puisse aussi
amener ben des vocations par rapport à
certains parce que le projet par
lui-même il est vraiment béton enfin je
trouve qu'il a il a vraiment lieu d'être
surtout à notre
époque
il voit pas la récupe il voit le côté
magique il voi la
locomotive arrêtons de surconsommer
arrêtons de jeter inutilement et voyons
ce qu'on peut réutiliser et recycler
pour éviter de produire plus et de
piocher dans dans nos réserves
naturelles l'obsescence programmé c'est
qu'on a des objets depuis pas mal
d'années qui ont une faim euh et nous on
veut montrer que ben non on peut leur
donner une deuxième vie comme je disais
tout à l'heure et que les fins c'est la
fin qu'on peut lui donner et que ce
monde nous a appris à jeter jeter jeter
jeter jeter alors que dans un temps pas
si lointain que ça ben on pouvait garder
des objets jusque toute notre vie voir
même la vie de nos enfants et
cetera